what we're going to do in this video is
take the region between the two curves y
is equal to square root of x on top and
y is equal to x squared on the bottom
and rotate it around a vertical line
that is not the y axis so we're going to
rotate it around the vertical line x is
equal to 2. we're going to rotate it
right around like that and we will get
if we rotate it like that we will get
this shape so the strange looking shape
it's hollowed out in the middle you can
kind of use the y equals x squared part
kind of hollows out the middle and it's
really the stuff in between that forms
the wall of this kind of rotated shape
so let's think about how we can figure
out the volume and we're going to do it
using the disc method sometimes called
the ring method actually it's going to
be more of the washer method to do this
one right over here
so we're rotating around a vertical line
we want to use our disc or ring or
washer method and so it'll be really
helpful to have a bunch of rings stacked
up in the y direction so we're probably
going to want to integrate with respect
to y let me make it clear what i'm
talking about each of our rings are
going to look something like this so let
me my best attempt to draw so that's the
inner radius
that's the inner radius of the ring
defined by y is equal to x squared
that's the inner radius and then the
outside radius of the ring might look
something like this
the outside
radius
my best attempt to draw it reasonably
the outside radius of the ring
might look something
might look something like that and the
depth of the ring
would be
a little d y
just like that so let me draw the depth
so let me see right over here you can
kind of view just the height of the ring
because we are thinking in a vertical
direction and that would be a ring for a
given y for say
this y right over here so it's
essentially the ring generated if you
were to take this rectangle
this rectangle of height d y
and rotate it around the line x equals
two and we're going to construct a ring
like that we're going to construct a
ring like that for each of the y's each
of the y's in our interval so you can
imagine stacking up a whole set of rings
just like this and then taking the sum
of the volumes of all of those rings and
the limit of that sum as you have an
infinite number of rings with or close
to infinite or really infinite number of
rings with infinitesimally small height
or depth or d y so let's figure out how
we would do this
well we know that all we have to do is
figure out what the volume of one of
these rings are for given y as a
function of y and then integrate along
all of them sum them all up so let's
figure out what the volume of one of
these rings are
and to do it we're going to express
these functions as functions of y
so our purple function
y is equal to square root of x
if we if we square both sides we would
get y squared
we would get y squared is equal to x
right and let me swap the side so it
makes it clear that now x is a function
of y
x is equal to
y squared that's our top function the
way we've drawn it in the kind of outer
shell for our figure
and then
y is equal to
x squared if you take the principal root
of both sides of that
it all works out because we're operating
in the first quadrant here that's the
part of it that we care about so you're
going to get x is equal to the square
root of y
x is equal to squared or y that is our
yellow function right over there
now how do we figure out the area of the
surface of one of these rings or one of
these washers
well the area let me do this in orange
because i drew that ring in orange so
the area of the surface right over here
in orange
as a function of y
so the area as a function of y is going
to be equal to the area of the circle if
i just consider the outer radius and
then i subtract out the area of the
circle constructed by the inner radius
just kind of subtracted out so the outer
circle radius so it's going to be pi
times
outer
outer radius
pi times outer radius squared
minus
pi pi let me write it this way
outer
well let me write i'll just write outer
radius it's going to be as a function of
y
outer radius squared
minus pi times inner
inner radius
radius squared and we want this all to
be a function of y so the outer radius
as a function of y
the outer
radius as a function of y is going to be
what
well it might be easier to actually i'll
try it both places so it's this entire
distance
it's this entire distance right over
here essentially the distance between
the vertical line the horizontal
distance between our vertical line and
our outer function the horizontal
distance between our vertical line
and our outer function so if you think
about it in terms of x it's going to be
minus whatever the x value is right over
here so the x value right over here is
going to be y squared remember we want
this as a function of y so our outer
radius is this whole distance is going
to be 2 minus the x value here as a
function of y that x value is y squared
so the outer radius is 2
minus
x sorry 2 minus y squared we want as a
function of y
2 minus y squared and then our inner
radius
our inner radius is going to be equal to
what
well that's going to be the difference
the horizontal distance between this
vertical line
and our inner function our inner
boundary so it's going to be the the
horizontal distance between 2 and
whatever x value this is but this x
value as a function of y is just square
root of
the square root of y so it's going to be
minus
square root of y
and so now we can come up with an
expression for area it's going to be and
i'll just factor out i'll leave the pi
there so it's going to be pi
i'll write it over here it's going to be
pi
times outer radius squared well the
outer radius is 2 minus y squared
and let me just well i'll just write it
minus y squared and we're going to
square that
squared
minus
pi times the inner radius squared well
we already figured that out the inner
radius is 2 minus
square root of y and we're going to
square that one too so this gives us the
area of one of our rings as a function
of y the the the top of the of the ring
where i shaded in orange and now if we
want the volume of one of those rings we
have to multiply it by its depth or its
height the way we've drawn it right over
here and it's height we've done this
multiple times already right over here
is an infinitesimal change in y so we're
going to multiply all that business
times
d y
this is the volume of one of our rings
and then we want to sum up all of the
rings over our interval so we're going
to sum up all of the rings over the
interval and when you take the integral
sign it's a sum where you're taking the
limit as as you have an infinite number
of rings that become infinitesimally
small in height or depth depending on
how you view it
and what's our interval
so we've looked at this multiple times
these two graphs you could do it by
inspection you could try to solve it in
some way but it's pretty obvious that
they intersect at remember these are we
care about our y interval they intersect
at y is equal to zero and y is equal to
one
intersected y equals zero and y equals
one and there you have it we have set up
our integral for the volume of this
shape right over here and i'll leave you
there and in the next video we will just
evaluate this integral